Sponsored by Newport Healthcare, providing results-driven treatment for teens and young adults ages 12 to 28 who are struggling with trauma, depression, anxiety, and other mood, personality, and co-occurring disorders. At Newport Healthcare, tailored treatment plans foster sustainable healing to help young people move from struggling to thriving. Learn more at newporthealthcare.com. Before we begin, you should know that this episode of Speaking of Psychology was recorded before. the racially motivated mass shooting at a supermarket in Buffalo, New York on May 14. The past two years have been a difficult time for most Americans, but they have taken a particularly heavy toll on the health, mental health, and well-being of people of color
本节目由Newport Healthcare赞助，为12至28岁受创伤、抑郁、焦虑及其他情绪、人格和共病障碍困扰的青少年和年轻人提供以结果为导向的治疗。在Newport Healthcare，量身定制的治疗方案旨在促进可持续的康复，帮助年轻人从挣扎走向蓬勃发展。欲了解更多信息，请访问newporthealthcare.com。在开始之前，您需要了解本期《心理学谈话》是在5月14日纽约州布法罗市一家超市发生种族动机的大规模枪击事件之前录制的。过去两年对大多数美国人来说都是一段艰难的时期，但它们对有色人种的健康、心理健康和福祉造成了尤为沉重的打击，
who have suffered disproportionately from the COVID-19 pandemic while also facing what some have called a second pandemic of racism. May is Mental Health Awareness Month, and the last week of this month will most. marked the second anniversary of the murder of George Floyd by Minneapolis police officer Derek Chauvin. What effect have these two intertwined situations, the pandemic and structural racism, had on the mental health and well-being of Black Americans and other people of color? More broadly, how has America's long history of racism and racial discrimination led to health inequities?
他们不仅在新冠疫情中遭受了不成比例的伤害，还面临着一些人所称的“种族主义第二疫情”。五月是心理健康宣传月，本月的最后一周将标志着乔治·弗洛伊德被明尼阿波利斯警官德里克·肖文谋杀两周年。这两个相互交织的情况——疫情和结构性种族主义——对黑人及其他有色人种的心理健康和福祉产生了什么影响？更广泛地说，美国长期的种族主义和种族歧视历史是如何导致健康不平等的？
And in the face of systemic racism and discrimination, what can be done to help people deal with racial stress and trauma and to protect children against their harmful effects. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Rihanna Elise Anderson. Dr. Anderson is a licensed clinical psychologist and an assistant professor in the Department of Health, Behavior, and Health Education at the University of Michigan.
面对系统性种族主义和歧视，我们能做些什么来帮助人们应对种族压力和创伤，并保护儿童免受其有害影响？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是蕾哈娜·埃莉斯·安德森博士。安德森博士是一位持证临床心理学家，也是密歇根大学健康、行为和健康教育系的助理教授。
School of Public Health. She studies how racial discrimination affects black children and families, and she develops interventions to reduce racial stress and trauma and improve psychological well-being. Dr. Anderson is the developer and director of the Embrace program, which stands for engaging, managing, and bonding through race. She speaks frequently to the media about racism and mental health and has been interviewed by CNN, the PBS News Hour, and the New York Times, among many other media outlets. Finally, Dr. Anderson was, as she frequently describes herself, born in, raised for and returned to Detroit. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Anderson. Thank you so much, Kim. So you gave a TED talk recently called vaccinating children against the virus of racism.
她在公共卫生学院任职。她研究种族歧视如何影响黑人儿童和家庭，并开发干预措施以减少种族压力和创伤，改善心理健康。安德森博士是“拥抱”（Embrace）项目的开发者和负责人，该项目代表“通过种族进行接触、管理和建立联系”。她经常在媒体上谈论种族主义和心理健康，并接受过CNN、《公共电视网新闻一小时》和《纽约时报》等多家媒体的采访。最后，正如安德森博士经常描述自己的那样，她出生于底特律，在底特律长大，并回到了底特律。感谢您今天加入我们，安德森博士。非常感谢你，金。你最近做了一个TED演讲，题目是“为儿童接种对抗种族主义病毒的疫苗”。
we've all had a lot of experience learning about viruses these past two years. What does it mean to think of racism as a virus and why is it useful to approach it that way? Kim, you said it perfectly. And so the first minute of the talk for folks who haven't had a chance to watch it, I set up this really what I consider a humanizing moment where I'm, I acknowledge I'm in a school of public health. And yet I didn't know a lot about virology. It just wasn't the area that I was a part of. And yet everyone learned a pretty good deal about vaccinations, viruses, et cetera, in the past two years.
过去两年我们对病毒有了很多了解。将种族主义视为一种病毒意味着什么？为什么用这种方式来处理它是有用的？金，你说得太对了。对于那些还没来得及观看演讲的人，我在演讲的第一分钟设置了一个我认为非常人性化的时刻，我承认我身处公共卫生学院，但我对病毒学了解不多。这并不是我所从事的领域。然而，过去两年每个人都对疫苗接种、病毒等有了相当多的了解。
So as I was initially taking my public health hat and learning so much about this virus, I was really struck by what I had actually started considering racism to be even before the pandemic hit. So a talk that I gave the December before the pandemic hit. someone said, it sounds like what you're doing is inoculation around racism and trying to prevent what we know to be in the air to impact these black children. I was like, oh, that's really interesting. So I started writing it and was actually going to give a talk in March 2020 about this very thing.
因此，当我最初戴上公共卫生专家的帽子，学习了这么多关于这种病毒的知识时，我真的被我甚至在疫情爆发前就开始认为种族主义所具有的特征所震撼。在疫情爆发前的那个十二月，我做了一次演讲，有人说：“听起来你所做的是围绕种族主义进行接种，试图防止我们所知的空气中存在的因素影响这些黑人儿童。”我说：“哦，这真的很有趣。”于是我开始撰写相关内容，并原定于2020年3月就此发表一次演讲。
So lo and behold, in May, as I'm starting to think through how we can make these comparisons, as you just noted in the intro, we have this murder that just creates a ripple throughout the world. And we see how one thing can spread and can impact so many people. And if we think about racism as this virus and one that I used to call them pandemic, but one that I now think of as endemic and understand as endemic because of this, time that's spent learning about viruses. I find it to be really useful. So I know I didn't just answer your question. Kim, I gave you a whole bunch of context, but that's how I started thinking about that comparison. So then how does the virus of racism actually harm the mental health and
果不其然，到了五月，当我开始思考如何进行这些比较时，正如你在开场白中提到的，那起谋杀案在全世界引起了连锁反应。我们看到了事物如何传播并影响如此多的人。如果我们把种族主义看作这种病毒——我过去称之为“大流行”，但现在因为这段学习病毒的时间，我将其视为“地方性流行病”并理解为地方性流行病——我发现它非常有用。我知道我没有直接回答你的问题，金，我给了你很多背景信息，但我就是这样开始思考这种比较的。那么，种族主义病毒究竟是如何损害黑人，
well-being of black people in particular and other people of color? Like what are the mental health consequences of racism and discrimination? Yeah. And this is something that is not disputed. There is data beyond question. There are data sets from every type of vantage point that you can look at, every statistical technique that demonstrates, not suggest, not correlates, demonstrates how an increase in racism leads to a number of physical, educational, et cetera. But since we're talking about psychology, the psychological impact is severe. We're talking depression. We're talking anxiety, PTSD, any sort of psychological internalizing problem is something that we can see, but it also extends to externalizing.
以及其他有色人种的心理健康和福祉的呢？种族主义和歧视会带来哪些心理健康后果？是的，这一点是毋庸置疑的。有来自各个角度的数据，有每一种统计技术都证明了——不是暗示，不是相关，而是证明了——种族主义的增加如何导致一系列身体、教育等方面的后果。但既然我们在谈论心理学，其心理影响是严重的。我们谈论的是抑郁、焦虑、创伤后应激障碍（PTSD），任何一种心理内化问题都是我们可以看到的，但它也延伸到了外化问题。
And those internalizing and externalizing problems are often those factors that then contribute to the physical, to the academic, to those extraneous variables. So those are the things that we really understand because it's happening to our mind and to our bodies then extends to the rest of the experience of these black children and their families. So speaking of children, much of your research is focused on kids. A lot has to do with giving families tools to talk to their children about race and racism. How and why do these tools and interventions work? I am very corny. So I think about this relationship of the X and the Y. So whether we're teaching it, whether we're talking about statistical analysis, if you can say there's a predictor
而这些内化和外化问题往往是导致身体、学术以及那些无关变量的因素。所以这些是我们真正理解的事情，因为它们发生在我们的思想和身体中，然后延伸到这些黑人儿童及其家庭的其余生活体验中。说到儿童，你的大部分研究都集中在孩子身上。很多工作与为家庭提供工具，让他们与孩子谈论种族和种族主义有关。这些工具和干预措施是如何以及为什么起作用的？我这个人很老套，所以我思考X和Y之间的这种关系。无论是教学还是统计分析，如果你能说存在一个预测因子
and an outcome, then you get the concept of an X to the Y. In the line of work that I think about, as I just talked about, you can draw a very straight and clear line from racism or discrimination to mental health problems. We know it. It's clear. One of the things that I am particularly consumed with or tasked with is this idea of how do we drop kick that relationship. If we know it exists. If we know that there's a problem, how do we intervene? How do we bend it? But again, I'm not satisfied with those types of statistical ways of changing it. I want to eviscerate it. I want to drop kick it. I want to annihilate it. I want it out of here. You know, I don't want it to happen. And if we know that it's really hard to take the X out of the equation, if it exists,
和一个结果，那么你就得到了X到Y的概念。在我思考的工作领域中，正如我刚才所说，你可以从种族主义或歧视到心理健康问题画出一条非常直接和清晰的线。我们知道这一点，很清楚。我特别关注或致力于的一件事是：如果我们知道这种关系存在，如果我们知道这是一个问题，我们该如何“踢开”它？我们如何干预？我们如何扭转它？但我对那些改变它的统计方式并不满意。我想彻底摧毁它，我想踢开它，我想消灭它，我想让它消失。你知道，我不希望它发生。如果我们知道很难将X从等式中剔除，如果它已经存在，
if discrimination or racism already exist, then what are the ways that we can mediate or moderate so that we can change that relationship to the outcome. So again, said in another way, how do we figure out what are the things that shift that relationship, the things that alter or moderate that relationship? And one of the ways that is most common, in particular in black families, is having discussions about it, not pretending that it doesn't exist, making it clear, making it plain,
如果歧视或种族主义已经存在，那么我们有什么方法可以进行中介或调节，从而改变它与结果之间的关系？换句话说，我们如何找出那些改变这种关系、改变或调节这种关系的事物？其中最常见的方法，特别是在黑人家庭中，就是进行相关讨论，而不是假装它不存在，把它说清楚，把它摆在台面上，
because that removes the psychological burden from children, that it's their fault, that they've done something to warrant it, that they're the only person that's experiencing this frustration or this treatment. It takes that away. So for children of color in particular, it gives them a context. And it not only serves as a more historical framing of it, but it also gives them the time to practice and to think through what do you want to do about this, to absolve themselves of that psychological stress and burden. So we have been talking a great deal about children of color, but it would be really important for us then to say if becoming aware of it is psychologically important for black children, one of the greatest
因为这消除了儿童的心理负担，让他们不再认为这是自己的错，不再认为自己做了什么才招致这种对待，也不再认为自己是唯一经历这种挫折或待遇的人。这消除了这些负担。因此，对于有色人种儿童来说，这为他们提供了一个背景。它不仅提供了一种更具历史性的框架，还给了他们练习和思考如何应对的机会，从而使他们摆脱那种心理压力和负担。我们一直在谈论有色人种儿童，但如果我们说意识到这一点对黑人儿童在心理上很重要，那么这对我们来说就非常重要了。目前世界上，或者说我们美国世界中最大的
debates that we're seeing in the world or in our American world right now is around, would this be psychologically damaging to children in classroom settings, for example? And the research is very clear that for all children, learning about racism, confronting it, talking about it, has psychological benefit and can absolutely reduce the psychological harm that they have not only for themselves, but reduces the behaviors that they might contribute to the psychological harm of others. So that's why our intervention, talking about it, making sure that we're intervening between racism and psychological outcomes is not only beneficial for the child herself, but for subsequent families and systems
争论之一是：这在课堂环境中对儿童是否有心理伤害？研究非常清楚地表明，对于所有儿童来说，学习种族主义、面对它、谈论它，都有心理益处，并且绝对可以减少他们不仅对自己造成的心理伤害，还能减少他们可能导致他人心理伤害的行为。这就是为什么我们的干预措施——谈论它，确保我们在种族主义和心理结果之间进行干预——不仅对孩子本人有益，而且对她之外的后续家庭和系统也有益。
outside of her. So how do we get that information in front of the people who at this time, I mean, I know you've heard all the debate about critical race theory and the things that are supposedly being taught in classrooms today, which, you know, isn't even true when we're talking at the elementary and high school level. But how do we get people to understand that it is important that these discussions have to happen in a classroom, not just at home, but you have to learn the history? Absolutely. So, you know, there are a number of people who are fighting. back. It can be at any level. So the teachers themselves who are fighting back, the politicians who know that within the states that they are in, maybe it's not a successful pushback,
那么，我们如何将这些信息传达给那些人呢？我知道你已经听到了关于批判性种族理论以及当今课堂上据称正在教授的内容的所有争论，而这些内容在小学和高中阶段甚至都不是真的。但我们如何让人们明白，这些讨论在课堂上发生是很重要的，不仅仅是在家里，你必须学习历史？绝对是这样。所以，你知道，有很多人在反击。这可以在任何层面进行。无论是反击的教师本人，还是那些知道在他们所在的州，这种反击可能并不成功，
but they're fighting and they're pushing. So when we think about ourselves of psychologists in the APA, there are so many things that we can do. There are a number of task forces and committees that I'm on that are looking at what are the policies and procedures that we can put forth that make a difference. So for example, there was a task force on the eliminate. of racism in our professional setting, but it has to start first with that acknowledgement of history. So we had two resolutions. The first was what was the role of psychology in racism? What was our role? What did we do? So we first acknowledged this was our history. This is what we have now contributed to some of our more current practices, right? So we acknowledge that first.
但他们仍在战斗和推动的政治家。因此，当我们想到作为美国心理学会（APA）的心理学家时，我们可以做很多事情。我所在的许多工作组和委员会正在研究我们可以提出哪些政策和程序来产生影响。例如，有一个关于消除我们专业环境中种族主义的工作组，但这必须首先从对历史的承认开始。所以我们有两项决议。第一项是心理学在种族主义中扮演了什么角色？我们的角色是什么？我们做了什么？所以我们首先承认这是我们的历史。这是我们现在对一些更现代的做法所做出的贡献，对吧？所以我们首先承认了这一点。
And now our committee is transitioning to what is it that we can do to rectify in the short term? And what are some of the longer term things that we have to do? So that historical dive as an organization can be done. Right? So in education, we can absolutely push to do the same thing that we just did with APA. I'm also a member of the Children, Youth, and Families Committee. And we're taking a look at what are the resources that we can compile from different organizations that we all have relationships with so that we can start sending
现在我们的委员会正在转向：我们能做些什么来在短期内纠正这些问题？我们必须做哪些长期的事情？因此，作为一个组织，这种历史性的深入挖掘是可以做到的。对吧？因此，在教育领域，我们绝对可以推动做我们刚刚在APA所做的事情。我也是儿童、青年和家庭委员会的成员。我们正在研究我们可以从我们都有联系的不同组织中汇编哪些资源，以便我们可以开始将其发送
it to educators or to local, more national levels and say, this is what we know. people are doing across the country, we want to have a compendium of resources for you so that if you're thinking about what you can do in your classroom, here are best practices. So there are absolutely things that people are doing. And I think what would be helpful is bringing them to one place so that people who might have questions on what are the things I can use, how can I do it, that we can make it more readily available for them. Well, I mentioned in the introduction that you've developed this intervention called the Embrace program, which puts a lot of tools like this into practice. Can you tell our listeners a little bit more about that? So there's been a great deal of
给教育工作者或地方、更高级别的机构，并说：这就是我们所知道的。人们在全国各地都在这样做，我们想为你提供一份资源汇编，这样如果你正在考虑在课堂上能做什么，这里有最佳实践。所以人们绝对在做一些事情。我认为有帮助的是将它们集中在一个地方，这样那些可能对“我可以使用什么，我该怎么做”有疑问的人，我们可以让他们更容易获得这些资源。嗯，我在介绍中提到你开发了一个名为“拥抱”（Embrace）的干预项目，它将许多这样的工具付诸实践。你能给我们的听众详细介绍一下吗？关于这个概念，已经有了大量的
research on this concept called racial socialization. And you may have heard of it colloquially as the talk. There have been a number of TV shows or commercials that show what it looks like for folks of color and parents and children in particular to have these conversations with each other. It's often in light of really traumatic situations like the murder of George Floyd. When those things happen, you often see families having to turn around. And again, acknowledge maybe there was this thing that I thought wasn't going to happen to you or to your generation. And maybe I thought I could protect you from this thing that I've experienced.
研究，叫做“种族社会化”。你可能在口语中听说过它叫“那次谈话”。有许多电视节目或广告展示了有色人种、父母和孩子在进行这些对话时的样子。这通常是在乔治·弗洛伊德被谋杀等非常创伤性的情况下发生的。当这些事情发生时，你经常看到家庭不得不回过头来。同样，承认也许有我以为不会发生在你或你这一代人身上的事情。也许我以为我可以保护你免受我所经历的这种事情的伤害。
And yet here it is now, plastered across the TV on our smartphone, on the headlines. It's there. We're not going to miss it. And kids are incredibly observant, right? So even if you don't tell them about it, they're going to figure it out. And they may often come to you and say, what is this? What is this thing that you haven't shared with me? So when we think about those talks, those conversations that people have again,
然而，它现在就出现在电视上、我们的智能手机上、头条新闻上。它就在那里。我们无法错过它。孩子们非常敏锐，对吧？所以即使你不告诉他们，他们也会弄明白。他们可能经常来问你：“这是什么？这是你没跟我分享的这件事吗？”所以当我们想到那些谈话，那些人们再次进行的对话时，
especially in light of these really tragic instances that are happening in our communities, these parents and children are having conversations to describe some of the feelings, some of the next steps that they want to have with respect to discrimination at large or discrimination in particular. What Embrace does is take that very rich literature and say, here are the different ways that psychologists or developmentalists in the past have observed families talking about race. And we take that more static or 2D knowledge of how people have talked about it and infuse it with, well, how can we grow something? some of their skills in it. What's the process that we can do to increase their skills?
特别是在我们社区发生的这些非常悲惨的事件背景下，这些父母和孩子正在进行对话，以描述一些感受，以及他们想要采取的一些后续步骤，关于广泛的歧视或特定的歧视。“拥抱”项目所做的是利用这些非常丰富的文献，并说：这是心理学家或发展心理学家过去观察到的家庭谈论种族的不同方式。我们采用这种关于人们如何谈论它的更静态或二维的知识，并注入：好吧，我们如何培养一些东西？培养他们在这方面的技能。我们能采取什么过程来提高他们的技能？
So we've now developed this approach of competency. How can we increase your skill, increase your confidence, and lower the stress that you have when you're engaging in these talks? Because it's not easy, y'all. If you're trying to talk to kids about race, whether you're a parent, a teacher, a friend to a young person, they're going to have some really good questions. They're going to hit you with some things that are hard as an adult to answer, but if you're loving that child, if you have a relationship to that child, it might be really hard to explain why someone called them a challenging word or made fun of their hair or their clothes, it could be really tough, not only because it's about that child,
所以我们现在开发了这种能力方法。我们如何提高你的技能，提高你的自信心，并降低你在进行这些谈话时的压力？因为这并不容易，各位。如果你试图和孩子谈论种族，无论你是父母、老师还是年轻人的朋友，他们都会提出一些非常好的问题。他们会问你一些作为成年人很难回答的问题，但如果你爱那个孩子，如果你与那个孩子有关系，解释为什么有人叫他们一个具有挑战性的词，或者取笑他们的头发或衣服，可能会非常困难，不仅因为这是关于那个孩子，
but because it's speaking to a part of you, right? So your own identity is wrapped up in this as well. So we try to just unpack a number of these things that might be happening in the conversation with parents and with children. And we do it important. importantly separately at first. So a lot of the adults that we work with haven't had the opportunity to unpack some of the things that have impacted them for decades. And they're telling us stories about what happened to them as children, things that they wish their parents would have said, things that happened when they were growing up, that they've kept with them that are surely going to impact the way that they talk to their children. But because no one's asked them about
而且因为它触及了你的一部分，对吧？所以你自己的身份也卷入其中。因此，我们试图拆解在与父母和孩子对话中可能发生的许多这些事情。而且我们首先重要地分开进行。所以我们合作的许多成年人还没有机会拆解几十年来影响他们的某些事情。他们告诉我们关于他们小时候发生的事情的故事，他们希望父母当时能说的话，他们成长过程中发生的事情，他们一直记在心里，这些肯定会影响他们与孩子交谈的方式。但因为没有人问过他们
them just as an adult, as a human. It's always with respect to being a parent. This is the first time that they could unpack. So we give adults the opportunity first just to unpack. We have kiddos unpack. And then we bring the family together and say, okay, from a family-based perspective, what are the ways that we can have these conversations more effectively with greater confidence? How can we practice? And then we give them tools to take home to practice. And I'll I'll acknowledge this is my favorite part about it. I called it homework. And a youth participant came back and said, oh, no, no, no, that was fun.
关于这些，仅仅是作为一个成年人，作为一个人类。这总是关于作为父母。这是他们第一次可以拆解这些。所以我们首先给成年人机会去拆解。我们让孩子们拆解。然后我们将家庭聚在一起说：好吧，从家庭的角度来看，我们有什么方法可以更有效地、更有信心地进行这些对话？我们如何练习？然后我们给他们带回家的工具来练习。我会承认这是我最喜欢的部分。我称之为“家庭作业”。一位青年参与者回来后说：“哦，不，不，不，那很有趣。”
That's fun work. Like, we like to do that. So that's called homework. That is not homework. So it is now fun work that they can take home to build those skills. So what about white families? I mean, white parents don't necessarily have these kinds of conversations with their kids. What advice do you give to white parents who want to raise anti-referms?
“那是‘有趣的工作’（fun work）。我们喜欢做那个。”所以那叫“家庭作业”。那不是家庭作业。所以现在它是他们可以带回家去建立这些技能的“有趣的工作”。那么白人家庭呢？我的意思是，白人父母不一定和他们的孩子进行这种对话。你给那些想培养反种族主义的白人父母什么建议？
racist children about how to talk to their kids? Step one is to talk. So I know that sounds really crass and I don't mean it to be, but the research is very clear with respect to how frequently white families are having conversations about race and that number is low. So very few families are talking about race. And sometimes what you'll see when you're conducting this research is that the mention of race, say a child says something about another person, for example, their hair looks like a cottonball, right? The parent will shush that child or say, we don't say things like that. And that for them counts as talking about race.
关于如何与他们的孩子谈论种族？第一步是谈论。我知道这听起来很粗鲁，我不是那个意思，但研究在白人家庭谈论种族的频率方面非常清楚，那个数字很低。所以很少有家庭在谈论种族。有时当你进行这项研究时，你会看到提到种族，比如一个孩子对另一个人说了些什么，例如，他们的头发看起来像个棉球，对吧？父母会“嘘”那个孩子，或者说：“我们不说那样的话。”而这对他们来说就算是在谈论种族。
They may see that as having a conversation about race, that they acknowledged it. When really what we're doing is demonstrating to that child that that's not something we can broach. That's not a topic that we can talk about. It's not spoken about here. which will discourage that child from bringing that back up. So anything that they experience for themselves, anything that's happening in school,
他们可能认为这算是在进行关于种族的对话，他们承认了这一点。而实际上我们所做的是向那个孩子证明，这不是我们可以谈论的话题。这不是我们可以讨论的话题。这里不谈论这个。这会阻止那个孩子再次提起这件事。所以他们自己经历的任何事情，学校里发生的任何事情，
anything they're seeing on the TV, we are now saying it's not important, it's not relevant, and it's not something that I value in talking to you. If we actually want a racism-free country or racism-free society, these conversations with white children in white families are actually the most important.
他们在电视上看到的任何事情，我们现在都在说这不重要，不相关，也不是我重视与你谈论的事情。如果我们真的想要一个没有种族主义的国家或没有种族主义的社会，这些在白人家庭中与白人儿童进行的对话实际上是最重要的。
So I think that my job as a black psychologist, working with black families is crucial because I know that black families are being harmed every day. But as I told you earlier, Tim, if we're talking about the X to the Y, my ultimate goal is to obliterate the X. I don't want racism to exist. Then I don't have to intervene. I don't have to work so hard to drop kick. There's nothing to drop kick. Nothing will be there. That means that we have to talk to white children who are often the perpetrators of racism to say the things that you saw today are unacceptable. We just had another murder in Grand Rapids in Michigan. We are grabbing our guns as police officers when we see black people more quickly. We are suspending children more rapidly.
所以我认为我作为一名黑人心理学家，与黑人家庭合作是至关重要的，因为我知道黑人家庭每天都在受到伤害。但正如我之前告诉你的，金，如果我们谈论X到Y，我的最终目标是消灭X。我不希望种族主义存在。那么我就不必干预了。我不必那么努力地去“踢开”它。没有什么可踢开的。什么都不会在那里。这意味着我们必须告诉那些往往是种族主义肇事者的白人儿童：你们今天看到的事情是不可接受的。我们刚刚在密歇根州大急流城又发生了一起谋杀案。当我们看到黑人时，我们作为警察会更快地掏枪。我们暂停孩子上学的速度更快。
We are clutching our purse more aggressively. We are doing a number of things when we see our black neighbors, our friends, our community members. And that is something that we should not do. And asking the child, what are some of the things that you think we can do to be better neighbors, to be better friends, bringing them into that conversation, soliciting their advice to get a sense of how can we be the generation that actually changes this trajectory in our world? That's something that we ask children from all backgrounds. It doesn't have to be, again, just black or white. But for all children, how can we be that generation to make the change? How can you be a better friend, neighbor, classmate? Those are really simple questions that we can ask to get this dialogue started.
我们更激进地抓紧我们的钱包。当我们看到我们的黑人邻居、朋友、社区成员时，我们正在做许多事情。而这是我们不应该做的事情。并询问孩子：你认为我们可以做些什么来成为更好的邻居、更好的朋友？让他们参与到对话中，征求他们的建议，以了解我们如何成为真正改变世界轨迹的那一代人？这是我们询问所有背景儿童的事情。它不必，再说一次，只是黑人或白人。但对于所有儿童，我们如何成为做出改变的那一代人？你如何成为一个更好的朋友、邻居、同学？这些是非常简单的问题，我们可以问这些问题来开始对话。
Sponsored by Newport Healthcare, dedicated to providing sustainable healing for young people struggling with psychological and behavioral issues, including depression, anxiety, trauma, PTSD, and substance abuse. Newport serves teens and young adults ages 12 to 28 at residential and outpatient programs nationwide, successfully addressing teen and young adult mental health conditions through tailored treatment, family support, and care that prioritizes cultural competence and cultural humility. Learn more at Newport Healthcare.com. So we recently ran an episode about stigma and mental health and the problem of stigma preventing
本节目由Newport Healthcare赞助，致力于为受心理和行为问题困扰的年轻人提供可持续的康复，包括抑郁、焦虑、创伤、创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）和药物滥用。Newport在全国范围内为12至28岁的青少年和年轻人提供住院和门诊项目，通过量身定制的治疗、家庭支持以及优先考虑文化能力和文化谦逊的护理，成功解决青少年和年轻人的心理健康状况。欲了解更多信息，请访问NewportHealthcare.com。我们最近做了一期关于污名化和心理健康的节目，以及污名化阻碍
people from accessing mental health services that they need. Do you see this stigma as a continuing major problem in communities of college, or do you think that attitudes toward mental health and mental health care are changing? They're changing really rapidly. I don't have the data to confirm that in this moment. But from everything that we're seeing on social media, for example, in particular, youth-led spaces like TikTok, there's so much emphasis on self-care, on seeking mental health treatment.
人们获得他们所需的心理健康服务的问题。你认为这种污名化在有色人种社区中仍然是一个主要问题吗？还是你认为人们对心理健康和心理保健的态度正在改变？它们正在迅速改变。我目前没有数据来证实这一点。但从我们在社交媒体上看到的一切，例如，特别是像TikTok这样以青年为主导的空间，对自我保健、寻求心理健康治疗的重视程度非常高。
And I'll couple that with embrace. one of the most challenging elements of embrace was the session length. So we have five sessions. They're about two hours each. Then we do pre and post test. So we're asking about 14 hours of people. And we were told by reviewers. We're told by funders.
我会把这一点与“拥抱”项目结合起来。拥抱项目最具挑战性的要素之一是课程长度。所以我们有五节课。每节课大约两个小时。然后我们做前测和后测。所以我们要求人们投入大约14个小时。我们被评审员告知，我们被资助者告知，
That's too much time. People are not going to want to spend that much time with you in therapy. The most consistent request from families when we end is why don't we have more sessions? why don't we have more time? And those two things combined for me, Kim, because what we're offering is culturally relevant and culturally appropriate and culturally attuned therapy. And the dialogue that we're engaging in
那时间太长了。人们不会愿意在治疗上花那么多时间。当项目结束时，家庭最一致的要求是：为什么我们不能有更多的课程？为什么我们不能有更多的时间？对我来说，金，这两件事结合在一起，因为我们提供的是文化相关、文化适宜和文化协调的治疗。我们正在进行的对话
is relevant for the problems for the people that we're serving. And so if we're thinking about a reduction in stigma, we can't just offer the same products and expect stigma to just reduce. So I think it takes a both-and approach, I think the current generation is more mindful that therapy is a fantastic product, but the product does have to actually meet their needs. So we're trying to do both at this time. So research continues to show this reluctance among some black people to seek care for mental health professionals because there's a sense among some black people that we take care of ourselves, right?
与我们所服务的人群的问题相关。所以如果我们考虑减少污名化，我们不能只是提供同样的产品并期望污名化自然减少。所以我认为这需要一种“两者兼顾”的方法，我认为当代人更意识到治疗是一个极好的产品，但产品确实必须真正满足他们的需求。所以我们目前正在尝试两者兼顾。所以研究继续表明，一些黑人在寻求心理健康专业人员的护理方面存在抵触情绪，因为一些黑人有一种感觉，即我们照顾我们自己，对吧？
Or that they feel more comfortable maybe talking to their pastor or another religious figure. what do you say to black people to encourage them to get care from a licensed mental health provider who might have a very different skill set from your pastor? Yeah, it's a great question, Kim. And I'll reflect back to a talk that I was able to give at my grandparents' former church. So my grandparents are no longer with us. But I got a request from them, the church. And I went to this very traditional black church in Detroit and remembered,
或者他们可能觉得与牧师或其他宗教人士交谈更舒服。你对黑人说什么来鼓励他们从持证心理健康提供者那里获得护理，而这些提供者可能拥有与你的牧师非常不同的技能组合？是的，这是一个很好的问题，金。我会回顾一下我能够在祖父母以前的教堂所做的一次演讲。我的祖父母已经不在了。但我收到了他们的请求，那个教堂。我去了底特律那个非常传统的黑人教堂，记得
growing up there and seeing all of these churchgoers, these parishioners who I could recall some of the messages that are consistent with what you're saying coming out of the church. And here I am being asked to talk about reduction of stigma in May for Mental Health Awareness Month. And I share with them analogies, and that's the way that I teach generally when I'm talking to people, whether it be in media in the classroom or 90-year-old grandmothers in the church, right? I use analogies and I start talking about mechanics. And if you've been to Detroit and you've experienced some of our potholes and you know your car hits those potholes, you're going to need to see a mechanic pretty soon.
在那里长大，看到所有这些去教堂的人，这些教区居民，我能回想起一些与你所说的一致的信息从教堂里传出来。而我在这里被要求在五月心理健康宣传月谈论减少污名化。我与他们分享类比，这就是我通常在与人交谈时的教学方式，无论是在媒体、课堂上还是在教堂里90岁的祖母面前，对吧？我使用类比，我开始谈论机械。如果你去过底特律，经历过我们的一些坑洼，你知道你的车撞到那些坑洼，你很快就需要去看修理工。
And you know why? I certainly don't have the skill set of a mechanic. If I opened up the hood, if I popped the hood and I went in there with my blunt tools and my nascent understanding, there's going to be a problem. If I tried to fix the axle, it'll probably fall off the next time I drive the car. So me trying to use my own skills or asking someone who is a dentist to take a look at my car. These are not skills that we're keen on, that we are able to utilize to fix this car. So when we're thinking about what a pastor does, a pastor does very great work in our churches,
你知道为什么吗？我肯定没有修理工的技能。如果我打开引擎盖，如果我掀开引擎盖，用我笨拙的工具和初步的理解进去，肯定会出问题。如果我试图修理车轴，下次开车时它可能会掉下来。所以我想用我自己的技能，或者让牙医去检查我的车。这些不是我们热衷的、我们能够利用来修理这辆车的技能。所以当我们思考牧师做什么时，牧师在我们的教堂里做了非常伟大的工作，
and our spaces, and it goes beyond pastoral care, right? This goes to mentorship as well. This goes to a number of in-house things that people might try to do. So the people we rely on to get our needs met can do them in ways that we are grateful for and have appreciation for. And people who have unique skill sets and are licensed in particular to utilize those skillsets have to abide by a set of laws, have to abide by a set of ethos and values that are going to be better for your care in this area.
在我们的空间里，它超越了牧师的关怀，对吧？这还涉及导师制。这涉及人们可能尝试做的许多内部事情。所以我们依赖来满足我们需求的人可以用我们感激和欣赏的方式来做。而那些拥有独特技能并特别获得许可利用这些技能的人，必须遵守一套法律，必须遵守一套比在这个领域对你的护理更好的道德和价值观。
in the long run. So I certainly don't say that pastors aren't important. They play a crucial role. And it's important for us to have them play their role as doctors are also supposed to play our role in the health and well-being of folk. So again, just to drive that point for the mechanics, I say you don't want to have the wrong person looking at your car. You don't want to have someone who doesn't have the appropriate skills that's looking at your mind, looking at your heart, looking at your body. And what I often get pushed back on more than anything is that while going to a primary care physician is okay, going to a mental health professional is not. And so I extended a bit again to say, we're simply popping the hood, right? So everything else might be about fixing other
从长远来看。所以我当然不是说牧师不重要。他们扮演着至关重要的角色。重要的是让他们扮演他们的角色，就像医生也应该在人们的健康和福祉中扮演我们的角色一样。所以，为了再次强调机械的观点，我说你不想让错误的人检查你的车。你不想让一个没有适当技能的人检查你的思想、你的心、你的身体。而我经常受到的反驳比什么都多的是，虽然去看初级保健医生是可以的，但去看心理健康专业人员是不行的。所以我再次扩展了一点说，我们只是在掀开引擎盖，对吧？所以其他一切可能都是关于修复你的其他
elements of you. But when we're talking about mental health, we're popping the hood. We're getting a sense of what's going on in your brain, what's going on in your mind, what can we do to help out a bit more with the way that you're thinking. So I try to use strategies like analogies to talk to folks. Sometimes it works, and hopefully with the grandmas and the church that I was at, it works too. And it's like a specialist. I mean, if you had heart disease, you'd go to a cardiologist.
元素。但当我们谈论心理健康时，我们是在掀开引擎盖。我们正在了解你的大脑里发生了什么，你的思想里发生了什么，我们能做些什么来帮助你更多地改善你的思考方式。所以我尝试使用像类比这样的策略来与人们交谈。有时它有效，希望在我所在的教堂里的祖母们那里，它也有效。这就像一个专家。我的意思是，如果你有心脏病，你会去看心脏病专家。
If you have a mental health condition, you see somebody who treats mental health. You do can, but the one thing that I'll say that I've missed this last time is the reason why people keep it in-house. So I think it's really important to acknowledge that in the past, if you said I have something that I'm concerned about, that I'm worried about, that's angering me. There could be consequences in your job, for example. So if you're trying to tell someone,
如果你有心理健康状况，你会去看治疗心理健康的人。你可以这样做，但我最后一次错过的一件事是人们把它留在内部的原因。所以我认为承认这一点非常重要，在过去，如果你说我有我担心的事情，我担心的，让我生气的事情。例如，你的工作中可能会有后果。所以如果你试图告诉某人，
they might look at you as incompetent or why did we hire this person, particularly, again, from a lens of, if you think about historical consequences, is if one was enslaved and said, I'm not feeling well. We learned very early on that you could not complain. There was no time to rest. There was no time to take time for yourself. So imagine the luxury then of the descendants of these ancestors in common parlance to be able to sit for an hour and talk about your feelings.
他们可能会把你视为无能，或者“我们为什么要雇佣这个人”，特别是，再次从一个视角来看，如果你考虑历史后果，如果一个人被奴役并说“我感觉不舒服”。我们很早就知道你不能抱怨。没有时间休息。没有时间为你自己花时间。所以想象一下，在普通话中，这些祖先的后代能够坐下来谈论你的感受，这是一种奢侈。
That's not something that historically has always been afforded to black people. So I think it's really important to acknowledge the historical, impact and what that has done. And I think it's a this and. And we do have services and opportunity now to do this. And it is not a luxury. It is something that we hope becomes a right, a privilege, something that you take up, something that you want and desire and we'll be happy to provide it. So one of the challenges that we face in psychology is having a development. diverse workforce. I mean, having appropriate providers available. APA's most recent data found that the psychology workforce is becoming more diverse, but that 83% of psychologists are white compared
这在历史上并不总是提供给黑人的。所以我认为承认历史影响以及它所做的事情非常重要。我认为这是一个“既……又……”的问题。我们现在确实有服务和机会来做这件事。这不是一种奢侈。这是我们希望成为一种权利、一种特权的东西，是你想要和渴望的东西，我们将很高兴提供它。所以我们在心理学面临的挑战之一是拥有一个发展的多元化劳动力。我的意思是，拥有可用的适当提供者。APA的最新数据显示，心理学劳动力正变得更加多元化，但83%的心理学家是白人，相比之下
with only about 60% of the population as a whole. How important is it to have a diverse mental health workforce? It's incredibly important, Kim. And it's not because the data on matching, for example, says that we have to have. black therapists with black clients. So for those that may not be available or excuse me, informed on what matching is. Matching is just you have the same race therapist or it could go to other identities, right? But in this case, if we're talking race, there's not a great deal of data demonstrating that you have to have race consistent matching for your therapeutic outcomes to be high, right? So I'm not suggesting that there has to be a match. But what I am suggesting is that
只有约60%的整体人口。拥有多元化的心理健康劳动力有多重要？这非常重要，金。并不是因为关于匹配的数据，例如，说我们必须有黑人治疗师与黑人客户。所以对于那些可能不知道或抱歉，不了解什么是匹配的人。匹配只是你有相同种族的治疗师，或者它可以延伸到其他身份，对吧？但在这种情况下，如果我们谈论种族，并没有大量数据证明你必须有种族一致的匹配才能使你的治疗结果很高，对吧？所以我不是建议必须有匹配。但我建议的是
throughout the training of these therapists, if you don't have diverse thought in the classroom, diversity in practice, if you don't have a number of ways to think about how we might be able to treat clients in a clinic, then we're missing out on opportunities of addressing challenges in different ways, right? So I certainly think the training atmosphere, generally speaking, would be beneficial or would be benefited by having folk of diverse backgrounds. I can certainly think about it from the perspective of client seeing me and saying out loud, wow, her hair curls like mine or like, wow, she looks like me. Like hearing that is really important for things that we may not be measuring.
在这些治疗师的整个培训过程中，如果你的课堂上没有多元化的思想，实践中没有多元化，如果你没有多种方式来思考我们如何在诊所中治疗客户，那么我们就错过了以不同方式解决挑战的机会，对吧？所以我当然认为培训氛围，总的来说，会因为拥有多元化背景的人而受益。我当然可以从客户看到我并大声说“哇，她的头发卷得像我的一样”或者“哇，她看起来像我”的角度来思考。听到这些对于我们可能没有测量到的事情非常重要。
So how long are people staying in therapy? How many referrals do we get because of that? So those are some of the things we may not be picking up on that are beneficial as well. We get a lot of snowball referrals from people within the same community once they see who's at the practice, right? So I think that that's incredibly important too. And I would be remiss if I didn't acknowledge some of the barriers that present itself to going into the professional space. So I know I always said I wanted to be a psychologist and I was very young, but I didn't really know how to become one. I didn't know anyone in Detroit who practiced. That just wasn't something we talked.
所以人们在治疗中停留多久？我们因为那个得到了多少转介？所以这些是我们可能没有注意到但也有益的事情。一旦人们看到诊所里有谁，我们就会从同一个社区的人那里得到很多滚雪球式的转介，对吧？所以我认为这也非常重要。如果我不承认进入专业空间所面临的一些障碍，我就会失职。所以我知道我总是说我想成为一名心理学家，我当时很年轻，但我真的不知道如何成为一名心理学家。我不认识底特律任何执业的人。那根本不是我们谈论的事情。
talked about or did, right? So I just, I don't know why I put my finger on it, but I was like, I want to be a psychologist. When you're talking about how much grad school may cost for some people, how much internship applications might cost, when you really sit down in total what people might be spending to get to the other side of this versus someone who may be in a more precarious financial situation that needs to get a job quickly, even if it's, $45, $50,000 for their family, that might mean the world, right? And so taking that money back and saying, this is my contribution versus I'm going to go into debt to get this lucrative career later on down the road.
谈论过或做过的事情，对吧？所以我不知道为什么我会有这种想法，但我当时就想，我想成为一名心理学家。当你谈到研究生院对某些人来说可能花费多少钱，实习申请可能花费多少钱时，当你真正坐下来计算人们为了达到这一目标总共可能要花费多少钱，而相比之下，有些人可能处于更不稳定的经济状况，需要尽快找到工作，即使这对他们的家庭来说只有4.5万或5万美元，那可能意味着全世界，对吧？所以，把这笔钱拿回来，说这是我的贡献，而不是为了以后获得这份高薪职业而背负债务。
So it's things like that where the APA, for example, needs to be mindful of how do we start investing in people very early on? How can we create opportunities for folks who may be financially disadvantaged to come to our profession. So we were talking a moment ago about two years since the killing of George Floyd, and even as we're speaking now, there are headlines about another black man being killed by police, Patrick Loyoya in Grand Rapids. Maybe this is an unfair question, and it's a little bit seat of the pants more than research-based, but do you feel like we're making any progress in the last few years in addressing racism and discrimination and trauma as a society.
所以，像美国心理学会（APA）这样的组织需要注意我们如何从很早就开始投资于人。我们如何为那些经济上处于劣势的人创造机会，让他们进入我们的行业。刚才我们谈到乔治·弗洛伊德被杀已经两年了，即使在我们现在交谈的时候，还有关于另一名黑人被警察杀害的头条新闻，即大急流城的帕特里克·利奥亚。也许这是一个不公平的问题，而且更多是即兴的，而不是基于研究的，但你觉得我们在过去几年里作为一个社会在解决种族主义、歧视和创伤方面取得任何进展了吗？
Oh, Kim, you are putting me in the hot seat here. So I have not as optimistic as some people might be with respect to our direction. And it's simply because from a sociological view, we're watching the pendulum swing back and forth when we think about progress. And we can start in more recent times with perhaps the election of Barack Obama, where there was so much hope and optimism coming from that and the immediate backlash of the subsequent administration. From there, there may have been a pendulum swing again with respect to 2020, and now we're watching CRT and that pendulum swing back, the anti-CRT initiative. So we're watching what happens when we try to make progress.
哦，金，你这是在让我难堪。所以，关于我们的方向，我并不像有些人那样乐观。这仅仅是因为从社会学的角度来看，当我们思考进步时，我们正在观察钟摆来回摆动。我们可以从最近的时期开始，也许是巴拉克·奥巴马的当选，当时从中产生了如此多的希望和乐观情绪，以及随后政府的立即反弹。从那里开始，关于2020年可能又出现了一次钟摆摆动，现在我们正在观察批判性种族理论（CRT）和那种钟摆摆动回来，即反CRT倡议。所以我们正在观察当我们试图取得进步时会发生什么。
And that swift, not reversal, I don't think that's fair either, but a swift softening or quieting or removal of that progress in certain spaces. But the optimist in me always does say this, Kim, that what we might consider insanity and that that term that or the logic around insanity that you have to do the same thing twice expecting different results, right? that common adage. One of the things that occurred to me in 2020 was that while systems might think that individuals are insane for resisting it, for going out into the streets, for marching, for protesting, for demanding justice, it is actually the systems that are insane for thinking
那种迅速的——我不认为是逆转，我觉得那样说也不公平——但在某些领域，那种进步的迅速软化、平息或消除。但我内心深处的乐观主义者总是这样说，金，我们可能认为的疯狂，以及关于疯狂的逻辑，即你必须做同样的事情两次却期望得到不同的结果，对吧？那句常见的格言。2020年我想到的一件事是，虽然系统可能认为个人因为抵制它、走上街头、游行、抗议、要求正义而疯狂，但实际上是系统本身疯狂，因为它们认为
that we will be quieted, for thinking that we won't be the ones demanding justice. So that is where I do think the power of the people is still very present and showing even if there is a pendulum swing, even if there is resistance, even if we're not making the type of progress or the pace of progress that many of us hoped we would see after 2020, what we did witness was that no amount of suppression would keep us down. We're watching right now some elections where four years ago, there was an attempt to suppress some of the abilities of folks in Georgia to vote a certain way or to have rights. And we're seeing what happens when that pendulum swings back for people to stand up and say, you thought it was going to, the pendulum would stick in one direction,
我们会安静下来，认为我们不会是那些要求正义的人。所以这就是我确实认为人民的力量仍然非常存在并显现出来的地方，即使有钟摆摆动，即使有阻力，即使我们没有取得许多人在2020年后希望看到的那种进步或进步速度，我们所见证的是，任何程度的压制都无法压垮我们。我们现在正在观察一些选举，四年前，有人试图压制佐治亚州民众以某种方式投票或拥有权利的能力。我们看到了当钟摆摆动回来时会发生什么，人们站出来说，你以为钟摆会固定在一个方向，
but we're actually bringing it back to come our way. So in essence, I was hoping that we would see more progress, that magically racism would be over, that my job would be complete and I could go to a beach and relax a little bit. But we are certainly seeing that people are not satisfied with anti-CRT policies or blatant racism, blatant white nationalism. We're seeing that people are not satisfied with that and are resisting and pushing back. So getting back to your work then as a psychologist, what is next on the horizon for you? What do you think are the big questions in your area that still need to be answered. Well, I thought I was clear when I said the beach, but let me try to give you something else
但我们实际上正在把它带回来，朝着我们的方向。所以本质上，我曾希望我们会看到更多的进步，希望种族主义会奇迹般地结束，我的工作会完成，我可以去海滩放松一下。但我们当然看到人们对反CRT政策或公然的种族主义、公然的白人民族主义并不满意。我们看到人们对这些并不满意，正在抵制和反击。那么回到你作为心理学家的工作，你接下来的前景是什么？你认为你所在领域中还有哪些重大问题需要回答？好吧，当我说海滩时，我以为我很清楚，但让我试着给你一些别的东西
if that's not satisfactory. Yeah, so I think that embrace, we were one week away from launching in Detroit, launching a larger study in Detroit when the pandemic hit. So it's been a really challenging two years trying to get the data that we need to extend the work, but that will be next, trying to get larger. samples so that if we're showing the proof of concept that we imagine we're showing from the pilot, that we'll be able to put this intervention to scale, that we'll be able to bring it to scale and get it some more hands, more people, more houses, and the U.S.
如果那不令人满意的话。是的，所以我认为那种拥抱，当大流行病来袭时，我们距离在底特律启动、在底特律开展一项更大规模的研究还有一周的时间。所以，试图获得我们需要的数据来扩展这项工作，这确实是充满挑战的两年，但那将是接下来的工作，试图获得更大的样本，这样如果我们展示了我们想象中从试点项目中展示的概念验证，我们将能够把这种干预措施扩大规模，我们将能够把它扩大规模，并让更多的人、更多的家庭和美国参与进来。
So in alignment with that, we're trying to think about what are the things that we know would be beneficial right now and how do we collaborate with the APA to create some resources for adolescents online? How do we create training for practitioners online and make that into a resource? So we're trying to take elements from this much bigger intervention and say, we know that this is effective. How do we get bits and pieces of it out into the world? So that's the big work that I'm doing over the next year or two.
因此，与此一致，我们正在尝试思考我们知道现在会有益的事情，以及我们如何与APA合作，为青少年在线创建一些资源？我们如何为从业者在线创建培训并将其转化为资源？所以我们正在尝试从这个更大的干预措施中提取要素，并说，我们知道这是有效的。我们如何将其中的点点滴滴带到世界上？所以这就是我在未来一两年内要做的重要工作。
And then the subsequent work is how do we learn better about what this discrimination experience is doing to children through things like VR experiences? So we've developed already a classroom experience along with the MIT former doc student. She developed this narrative around a teacher in a classroom setting discriminating against a child. And now we're developing with Detroit public school students that narrative for policing and what impact that has on our black children. When they put on this VR headset, we're getting this gestural experience. So what are they gesturing? what's their heart rate doing? What are they looking at? What are they feeling beyond just pin and paper?
接下来的工作是，我们如何通过虚拟现实（VR）体验等方式，更好地了解这种歧视经历对儿童的影响？所以我们已经与麻省理工学院的前博士生一起开发了一种课堂体验。她围绕一名教师在课堂环境中歧视一名儿童开发了这个叙事。现在我们正在与底特律公立学校的学生一起为警务工作开发这种叙事，以及这对我们的黑人儿童有什么影响。当他们戴上这个VR头显时，我们正在获得这种手势体验。所以他们在做什么手势？他们的心率如何？他们在看什么？除了纸和笔，他们感觉到了什么？
I'm nervous, right? I'm anxious. So we're getting so many different metrics and ways of thinking about discriminatory experiences. And that's the next thing after that. Yeah, that sounds exciting. And for people who can't participate right now in the program that you have, where might they go to get some resources that can help parents, especially when they have to have the talk? Yeah, so definitely wanting to highlight what the American Psychological Association's Resilience Initiative, that's racial and ethnic socialization. That's what the RES stands for. So if you type in Resilience Initiative, APA, you'll be able to find a number of age appropriate, worksheets, books, videos, et cetera. So definitely a shout out to APA for that. There are a number
我很紧张，对吧？我很焦虑。所以我们正在获得如此多不同的指标和思考歧视经历的方式。这就是那之后的事情。是的，这听起来很令人兴奋。对于现在无法参与你所拥有的项目的人，他们可以去哪里获得一些可以帮助父母的资源，特别是在他们必须进行那种谈话时？是的，所以绝对想强调美国心理学会的复原力倡议，那是种族和民族社会化。这就是RES所代表的含义。所以如果你输入复原力倡议，APA，你将能够找到许多适合年龄的工作表、书籍、视频等。所以绝对要为APA点赞。还有许多
of other organizations that have it as well, including my partners Embrace Race, Sesame Street, PBS. Yes, there are so many spaces that have these. So please don't think that these resources aren't compiled in some way. All of these wonderful organizations have just indicated have things ready to go by age and even by again your relationship to the child. So maybe parent, maybe teacher, but it's there. Okay. And we can put links to some of these in the program notes when we get this posted on the website.
其他组织也有这些资源，包括我的合作伙伴Embrace Race、芝麻街、PBS。是的，有太多的空间拥有这些资源。所以请不要认为这些资源没有以某种方式汇编。所有这些我刚刚提到的精彩组织都有准备好的东西，按年龄甚至按你与孩子的关系分类。所以也许是父母，也许是老师，但它就在那里。好的。当我们把这个发布在网站上时，我们可以在节目说明中放入其中一些链接。
And thank you for promoting APA and doing my job for me today. You're welcome. So it's great talking to you, Dr. Anderson. and I really appreciate the work that you're doing. Thank you so much. Likewise, and have a wonderful rest of your death. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www.org or wherever you get your podcasts.
感谢你今天为我推广APA并替我完成工作。不客气。很高兴与你交谈，安德森博士。我非常感谢你所做的工作。非常感谢。同样，祝你余下的一天过得愉快。你可以在我们的网站www.apa.org或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。
And if you listen to us on Apple, please leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condayan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你在Apple上收听我们，请留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Weinerman制作。我们的声音编辑是Chris Condayan。感谢收听。代表美国心理学会，我是Kim Mills。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。